bonsoir je m'appelle et catherine la
baie et je suis thérapeute et formatrice
on énergétique
recchi ce soir je suis venu vous parler
de l'amour l'amour avec un grand a
et pour commencer je vais m'adresser à
vous mesdames présente dans cette salle
qui a déjà accru le prince charmant qui
a déjà crû au prince charmant messieurs
vous aussi vous pouvez levez la main si
vous avez cru en la princesse n'a pas
beaucoup et bien moi j'y ai cru enfin
non pas vraiment pas le prince charmant
comment longtemps en fait quand j'étais
petit je percevais et je ressentais la
présence d'un homme à mes côtés la
présence d'un homme que je ressentais
comme mon amoureux et même comme la
personne qui m'était destinée alors
cette image cette présence n'était pas
alimenté par les dessins animés ou par
les contes de fées non c'était autre
chose et je le ressentais vraiment à mes
côtés et je sentais qu'il avançait vers
moi et même qui faisait partie de moi
c'est vrai que j'étais une enfant qui
était sensible intuitive et et que voilà
c'était particulier peut-être puis j'ai
grandi je me suis un peu éloigné de
cette image ce ressenti j'ai eu mes
expériences j'ai eu mes premiers amours
j'ai vécu en couple aussi à plusieurs
reprises mais je n'ai pas trouvé le
bonheur parfait le bonheur parfait c'est
ce qu'on peut décrire en surface parfois
comme à ce mec mais franchement il est
super mignon il est super sympa à temps
il a un super job il t'amène un week end
il t'offre des fleurs franchement moi
mais comme ça je lui met la main dessus
et je le lâche pas quoi non en fait
c'est vrai que ça pouvait nourrir et
partie de moi mais il y avait une autre
partie de moi qui a qui manquait quelque
chose à quelque chose de c'était pas des
cadeaux s'était pas c'était de même pas
plus d'attention
non c'était quelque chose de bien plus
authentique de plus profond de plus
essentiel est en fait ce que je
ressentais ce que je cherchais c'était
cet amour véritable que j'avais ressenti
quand j'étais enfant
ce que j'avais pu toucher du doigt cette
présence cet homme qui était près de moi
et mon âme en fait nous demandait de me
nourrir à nouveau de cet amour et puis
là mon âme frappé à ma porte
mais je savais pas comment lui répondre
mon âme frappé à ma porte et je savais
pas comment lui répondre et alors je me
suis de plus en plus reconnecter à cette
petite fille que j'avais été à cette
partie de moi qui faisais que j'avais pu
ressentir cette énergie cette présence
cet homme que je ressentais comme la
personne qui m'était destinée était
particulier parce que sa présence nous
nourrissait d'un amour qui faisait que
je me sens plein air je me sentais
pleine entière
mais d'une part
ti dont moi-même et j'étais dans une
sorte de bonheur de plénitude qui me
nourrissais donc j'ai commencé à mettre
de côté les standards les schémas et ce
qu'on attendait aussi deux mois pour
pouvoir justement laisser cette partie
de mon être s'exprimer à nouveau
c'était quelque chose de particulier
puis après avoir cheminé et chercher
l'amour en moins cet amour par une suite
de synchronicité qui ont mêlé des
personnes mais qui se connaissaient
absolument pas on m'a remis un post it
un post it sur lequel était simplement
écrit un nom et puis ce message
contactez le sait pour leproux bon ok
sur le coup je les ai perdus et j'ai
retrouvé quelques jours plus tard pour
déjà rien que voir de voir comment on
arrive là pour ce réal ce post it il
permis de croire que le peut-être s'il
ya autre chose que le hasard puis
finalement je me décide à contacter ce
monsieur mais en fait je ne savais pas
du tout ce que je cherchais c'était pour
le professionnel mais j'ai un peu
envoyez un message comme une bouteille à
la mer je me suis dit que lui
certainement saurait pourquoi je le
contacte donc je lui envoie un message
très professionnelle bonjour monsieur je
vous contacte de la part de claudine je
suis thérapeute je vais m'installer et
voilà il paraît gros que vous pouvez
m'aider donc voilà bien à vous sauf que
manque de bol il n'en savait pas plus
que moi et puis me répond un message
très court à merci on chantait
je crois pas connaître claudine mais bon
si je peux vous aider d'histoire en quoi
finalement
on échange quelques mails et puis on
parle d'un projet que qu'il avait qui
ressemblait beaucoup au mien et c'était
spécial parce que au delà des mots au
delà de ce qu'on avait pu échanger tout
ça résonnait fortement mois et il se
passe est autre chose que je comprenais
pas
donc finalement on a décidé de se
rencontrer faire connaissance dans un
lieu public les discuter et donc j'ai
rencontré ludovic c'est le nom de ce
fameux post it et à ce moment là je ne
savais pas mais ludovic était aussi ma
flamme jumelles donc on se retrouve ce
jour ci autour de ce projet enoch le
jour j j'étais sur le parking et
j'attendais je l'avais jamais vu et là
je vois sortir de sa voiture à quelques
dizaines de mètres de moi et j'ai
vraiment une drôle de sensation
je les ai vus sortir ses cheveux étaient
poivre et sel
ils étaient plus âgés que moi et je
reconnaissais cette allure cette
démarche qui m'était familière bon drôle
d'impression j'y prête pas plus
attention que ça et donc on commence à
discuter de nos vies personnelles
professionnelles ce qui nous avait
ramené autour de ce projet là il ce
rendez-vous ce jour-là est toujours une
troll de sensations et et au moment en
fait qu'on a arrêté le rendez-vous de
l'entretien ça faisait six heures qu'on
discutait on n'avait pas vu le temps
passer et en fait c'est le temps et est
comme suspendu bon et puis en partant à
la voiture il le dit si c'est ok pour
vous c'est ok pour moi et on travaille
ensemble sur ce projet
et en fait je lui ai dit oui avec une
grande évidence alors que je venais de
le rencontrer il ya quelques heures
mais c'était tellement naturel et voilà
je me suis fait confiance et ce jour là
quand on s'est regardés en partant nos
regards sont allés au delà de nos yeux
physique c'est comme sont plongés chacun
dans le regard de l'autre et on est
partis chacun de notre côté donc très
vite
en fait on s'est rendu compte après
avoir échangé que on avait eu un
parcours au personnel qui faisait que on
aille travailler en nous que l'amour
chacun de notre côté on avait travaillé
sur cette problématique en nous et nos 2
à 2,2 être finalement s'étaient
retrouvés après tout un parcours qui
avait été fait chacun notre rythme
chacun à notre niveau et comme qui on
était et c'est ça qu'on partageait à ce
moment là alors j'aimerais préciser deux
points importants c'est que l'on entend
souvent parler de la notion d'âme soeur
les âmes soeurs on peut en rencontrer
plusieurs au cours de notre vie aussi
bien des hommes que des femmes dans nos
connaissances dans nos amis dans notre
famille et parfois dans des relations
affectives et ce lien d'un tsar est
quelque chose de ford fusionnelle et
quand on l'a peut-être vous reconnaîtrez
vous dans une relation passée à la une
personne avec qui c'était spécial
quant aux à la notion de flemme jumelles
c'est différent parce que les flammes
jumelles on en a qu'une
en fait c'est la personne qui vous est
destiné c'est votre autre et
cette relation est très particulière
aller hors norme pour celles et ceux qui
ont pu la vivre parce que les flammes
jumelles soudan fait connectez l'une à
l'autre en permanence et par exemple
elles peuvent à distance ressentir la
présence de l'autre elles peuvent
partager même vivre ça serait plus le
terme les choses les états que l'autre
peut vivre c'est bien le physique des
maux physiques que des émotions
là par exemple je sens qu'il est pas là
ce soir
maki stress pour moi en ce moment et je
sais que c'est pas mon stress même si
moi aussi je vois là je suis devant vous
ce soir et c'est pas forcément facile il
ya des choses très particulière il ya
aussi une sorte de entre ces deux
personnes de ressemblance même si nous
sommes très différents
parce que nous avons 16 ans d'écart il
ya ce côté comme les jumeaux il dégage
quelque chose et par exemple quand l'un
commence une phrase l'autre
naturellement la fini voilà sont des
petites choses il ya encore d'autres
choses à dire mais j'ai m'arrêter là
donc ça c'était la différence entre les
hommes sarr et les flammes jumelles donc
très vite nous avons commencé à
travailler sur le projet et moi je me
suis blindé dans le boulot travail
projet boulot trail projet je voulais me
sentais qu avait des choses qui se
passaient mais ça me faisait part et je
voulais pas voir
et justement où malgré ça je sentais
qu'il y avait quelque chose de fort qui
nous liait je ne comprenais pas et
surtout que je contre les pins et puis
dans la carte du monde
c'était pas possible que je puisse entre
guillemets aimer un homme d'une manière
dont je n'ai jamais aimé cet homme qui
était si différent demain c'est un homme
qui avait 16 ans de plus que moi
si il y avait beaucoup de différences et
j'étais pas voilà c'était particulier
puis en même temps il avait des choses
qui se passaient d'hors norme mais qui
s'imposait à nous naturellement qu'ils
ne me dérangeait pas plus que ça
justement quand je sentais sa présence à
mes côtés et que je le ressentais à
distance ou encore
effectivement quand je commençais une
phrase et qu'il a terminée et que
c'était comme si on parlait tous les
deux d'une seule et même voix et puis
quand les gens dans la rue se retourner
je regardais sur moi si j'avais pas un
truc et je sais pas il paraît qu'on
dégager quelque chose de particulier
quand on était ensemble ou encore pour
tous rapportés on avait les mêmes gestes
les mêmes attitudes en même temps on se
voyait par donc si on était l'un à côté
de l'autre par exemple
ym ou encore quand l'un vivait quelque
chose de difficile et que l'autre le
ressentait à 100 km voilà plein en plein
de choses comme ça
puis un jour j'ai lâché prise et je me
suis dit maintenant il faut que
j'accepte ce qu'il est parce que c'est
évident on est relié on est connecté et
je ressentais comme faisant 1 avec lui
donc peu de temps après nous étions
ensemble aussi bien dans la vie
professionnelle qu'en couple dans la vie
personnelle et un an après nous avons
dépassé la dualité en donnant naissance
à notre fils ange
retrouvez et vivre sa flamme jumelles
c'est une chance un privilège mais
contrairement à ce qu'on peut croire ce
n'est pas tout rose
et ce n'est pas forcément un conte de
fées du moins ça peut le devenir mais
parfois après des périodes difficiles et
douloureuses je dis ça parce que quand
on se reconnecte à sa flamme jumelles
donc c'est une reconnexion à la base qui
se fait au niveau des arts une
reconnaissance qui se fait au niveau des
âmes on est tous content ou ce qu'on vit
tout ce qu'on ressent chacun le vit de
manière décuplée aussi bien l'égalité
que les défauts et les blessures c'est
comme si en fait on était mis en lumière
sous les feux des projecteurs comme là
ce soir et qu'on pouvait pas se cacher
que tout ressort du coup j'ai dû
accepter de lever mais voile sur les
illusions de m'accepter comme qui
j'étais pour pouvoir vivre un monde
harmonieusement cette relation
et puis j'ai dû travailler sur mes
blessures mais blocage mes freins mais
par mes blessures
étant donné que je suis thérapeute
formatrice en énergétique
j'ai utilisé le reiki l'énergie reiki
pour travailler en moins bien sûr
ludovic aussi a fait ce chemin là à
travailler en lui parce que ça nous
concerne tous les deux
à ce moment-là tout coule beaucoup plus
facilement et on peut être maintenant
dans le monde devait s que vivre avec sa
flamme jumelles c'est de pouvoir vivre
et peut créer chaque jour chaque chose
au quotidien dans un amour véritable
d'ailleurs ludovic et moi nous sommes
donc dans la vie personnelle et
professionnelle ensemble h 24 pour pas
vous mentir c'est la première fois en
quatre ans et demi que ce kit ce qui n'a
pas pu venir ça ça et je me suis souvent
demandé on s'est souvent demandé si on
était pas un peu fou si on n'était pas
dans une grande illusion et seulement on
était quand même deux à ressentir et
vivre tout ça de la même manière et
c'était aussi très réelle mais nous ne
sommes pas les seuls
et je vous dis ça parce que quand on
s'est mis ensemble
j'ai créé un blog sur les flammes
jumelles sur lequel j'ai raconté notre
histoire
j'ai partagé nos expériences et j'ai
reçu beaucoup de témoignages de
personnes partout dans le monde très
différentes qui vivent elles aussi
l'amour des flammes jumelles des
médecins chercheurs étudiants
professeurs coach thérapeute personnes
sensibles aux énergies subtiles
peut-être comment mais d'autres aussi
qui n'ont rien avant à ricky qui
ressemble quand même qui se passe
quelque chose aujourd'hui j'accompagne
les personnes aussi qui qui sont sur
cette quête du moins j'essaye de les
informer
les aider et pour terminer si vous le
souhaitez je sois dresse ce soir vous
tendre la main et je vous invite alors à
vous reconnecter à cette partie de vous
que peut-être comme moi vous avez
entendu quand vous étiez enfant
cette partie de vous qui sait ce qu'est
l'amour véritable
cette partie de vous qui peut aussi vous
nourrir en cet amour plein et entier et
cette partie de vous qui peut être un
jour vous guidera vous aussi vers votre
flamme jumelles merci